(upbeat music)
♪ Get into the bag, I want all of that ♪
♪ Got her number but
I ain't calling back ♪
♪ Automatic whip, no stalling that ♪
♪ Man will call the plays
like a quarterback ♪
♪ Get into the bag, I want all of that ♪
♪ Got her number but
I ain't calling back ♪
♪ Automatic whip, no stalling that ♪
♪ Man will call the plays
like a quarterback ♪
♪ Get into the bag, I want all of that ♪
♪ Got her number but
I ain't calling back ♪
♪ Automatic whip, no stalling that ♪
♪ Man will call the plays
like a quarterback ♪
♪ Get into the bag, I want all of that ♪
♪ Got her number but
I ain't calling back ♪
♪ Automatic whip, no stalling that ♪
♪ Man will call the plays
like a quarterback ♪
♪ I'm running up checks like a doctor ♪
♪ I'm trying to win gold like Oscar ♪
♪ A new flow, try and
do it too, impostor ♪
♪ Got them all running
off the beat like Costa ♪
♪ My team got a five-star roster ♪
♪ Your bitch threw a
fit when I tossed her ♪
♪ If she wanna fuck
twice, that'll cost her ♪
♪ Leave me be, get out my face ♪
♪ I secured the bag and went on my way ♪
♪ They behind, they're not on my page ♪
♪ Go learn to grind and get on my wage ♪
- [Man] Hey.
- [Femi] Oh look, here we go.
The zombies are back again.
- [Man] Keep it down.
I told you like don't
fuckin' come around here.
- Please give us a hit, please
- Where's your P?
- It's right here.
(bag rustles)
- [Man] That ain't no fucking money, man.
- It's got Bluetooth.
- So everyone's got Bluetooth cousin.
My ancestors have got Bluetooth.
Bring me somethin' more interesting
like a iPad or somethin'.
- Can we just get two white pieces?
Come on man, it's worth two stone
and it's not that bad,
like you can, you know.
- [Guy] Yo, fuck off man.
Dris, the Turks.
- Fuck off.
- My friend.
Good news for you.
- Ya, that makes a change.
- You're going to need moneys.
- You always need moneys
when you see us people.
- This time is fifty.
- Fifty?
- Price is high my friend.
You want oranges, you want pineapple,
you pay more moneys, no?
Everybody's paying more
moneys for everything.
Cars, food, coffee.
It's Brexit.
(mumbles in foreign language)
- [Man] Speak fucking English, man.
- My friend say, you is a man.
But I say you is woman, no?
- Why you wash your wife?
- My wife?
Look, you don't want, is no problem.
Call you later, huh?
Tell you place, time.
- [Femi] Why you let
him treat us like that?
You know that.
- Dick head, little pussy.
"I'll call you later,"
what the fuck does that mean?
- What were you sayin'?
Roman, put your arm down.
- Hey Fem, what's wrong with this bike?
- [Femi] You broke it.
- No, it just started broke, it's fucked.
- [Man] Bros, calm bro.
- [Femi] I'll fix it.
(bike crashes)
(laughs)
- Stop fuckin' about, man.
- [Biker] You stop muckin' about.
Why did you just trash the
bike for no reason though?
(lowkey music)
♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
♪ I don't know what they
want, I don't know ♪
♪ In the cold with my G's, in the cold ♪